y con nuestro primer invitado el día
vamos a hablar de la crisis política y
social que se vive en Perú desde el mes
de diciembre esto tras la destitución y
detención del expresidente Pedro
Castillo las protestas aquí han tenido
lugar en varias ciudades de ese país han
dejado hasta la fecha 47 personas
fallecidas los manifestantes piden la
salida del poder de la actual presidenta
y nuevo Duarte y elecciones generales
inmediatas Mientras que el congreso el
día de ayer martes aprobó un voto de
confianza al gabinete del Primer
Ministro Luis Alberto otálora saludamos
entonces a nuestro primer invitado Omar
Cairo él es abogado de la Universidad de
Lima y magíster en derecho
constitucional de la pontificia
Universidad Católica de Perú Omar
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de miércoles en directo América
de Francia 24 y digamos para empezar y
dar un contexto a nuestra audiencia
hasta el momento hasta el día de hoy
como ve todo lo que ha pasado desde que
inició esta nueva crisis política en
Perú cuando salió el poder el
expresidente Pedro Castillo
bueno el inicio de la crisis es una
confusión y la y el punto en el que
estamos es uno en el cual muy
probablemente se han cometido crímenes
de lesa humanidad
por haber
reprimido las movilizaciones
violentistas o no pero disparando a la
población y en dos fechas diferentes lo
cual Crea una situación que en un
momento voy a explicar cómo complica al
gobierno la confusión se centra en lo
siguiente el día siete de diciembre en
la mañana Pedro Castillo es presidente
constitucional y en la noche
está preso y Dina boluarte es la
presidenta del Perú entonces Esto fue
interpretado en el interior del país
sobre todo en el en el sur como la el
despojo por parte del Congreso de la
presidencia a Castillo y su entrega Dina
boluarte Y esto no fue lo que ocurrió lo
que pasó en ese en esas horas es que en
la mañana a las once aproximadamente
Castillo da un mensaje a la nación
realizando un golpe de estado porque
clausura el congreso sin que se
presenten los supuestos para la
disolución previstas en la corte
imprevistos en la Constitución
declara la reorganización del sistema de
justicia de todos los tribunales y
convoca elecciones para una para un
Congreso Constituyente esto no está
permitido con la por la Constitución
entonces él se él es un en ese momento
se convierte en un gobernante de facto
el artículo 46 de la Constitución
Establece que nadie le debe obediencia
en ese momento él perdió el cargo
estamos hablando de las once y media de
la mañana
sin embargo en la tarde el congreso al
expresidente le practica un
procedimiento
de vacancia por incapacidad moral
distorsionando la figura porque la
vacancia simplemente para declarar que
el cargo está vacío pero el congreso lo
presenta como un castigo y se van a
Gloria de haber destituido a Castillo lo
cual no es cierto porque Castillo ya
había perdido el cargo sí por virtud del
artículo 46 Y entonces hacen una
votación
se toman fotos este casi riéndose por
por lo que ha pasado y eso lo muestran a
la población entonces en el interior
tienen impresión de que Castillo ha sido
destituido por el congreso claro y que
el congreso ha nombrado a boluarte como
como presidenta lo cual repito no es
cierto Castillo perdió el cargo Cuando
dio el golpe de estado y por mandato de
la Constitución
debía asumir Dina boluarte pero esta
cuestión ha llevado a que en el interior
del país se crea que Castillo el
presidente despojado y por lo tanto que
se pida la renuncia de la gobernante
presuntamente golpista que Dina boluarte
Y eso originó todo y ahora no sé si
tienes alguna precisión que hacer Sí Sí
Omar quería hablar sobre todo de las
protestas que se han visto en en varias
localidades de Perú desde que ocurrió
esto con el expresidente Castillo desde
que ya no está en el está la actual
presidenta Dina boluarte hablabas
también de que se dio la orden digamos
de disparar munición Real contra estos
manifestantes quién pudo haber dado esta
orden y que realmente está pasando en
estos choques entre manifestantes y la
policía además también
digamos que llama la atención que
después de 47 muertos hasta el momento
boluarte todavía digamos sigue en el
poder y no se ve como una
tratar de resolver esta situación de
orden público en todo el Perú
sí lo que ocurre es que esta
movilizaciones se originan por esa
confusión para porque en el interior del
país se pide la devolución del cargo a
castillo y entonces hay movilizaciones
algunos violentistas infiltrados pero la
respuesta es la declaratoria del estado
de emergencia la entrega al al ejército
del control interno para para
restablecer el el el la situación
de paz y en ese contexto se produce en
el mes de diciembre
muertes porque las fuerzas de seguridad
disparan a la población
en ese momento
el responsable político es el ministro
de defensa y el ministro interior a qué
me refiero con responsable político es
aquel que debe perder el cargo por el
desacierto del manejo de la crisis
entonces la presidenta debería haberle
dicho y la crisis se ha manejado matando
a veintinueve personas ustedes están por
el cargo Pero qué hace la presidenta
mantiene al ministro del interior y al
presidente al ministro de defensa lo
asciende a presidente del Consejo de
ministros Y entonces ya se genera una
impresión de que es posible que ella
esté convalidando lo que ha ocurrido y
esto se agudiza cuando ya después de
esto ocurre una segunda matanza que es
el nueve de enero donde cuarenta y cinco
personas mueren en un solo día y la
presidenta aparece en la televisión
dando sus condolencias Pero en ningún
momento
condenando el hecho de que se haya
disparado a la población y simplemente
dice no destituye a nadie no destituye a
los jefes militares y entonces se coloca
en una situación en la cual es era
posible ese en ese momento sí que se le
imputaran crímenes de lesa humanidad por
la esta teoría del dominio del hecho no
porque ella haya disparado sino porque
haya ella haya ordenado o convalidado o
aceptado que esto ocurra Y ayer la
fiscal de la nación del Perú le ha
iniciado un proceso por genocidio crimen
de persecución internacional sí
Inclusive si es que en el Perú no
prospera cualquier juez porque es un
delito de persecución universal en
cualquier lugar del mundo la puede
procesar y cuando deja de ser presidente
la puede aprender Y encarcelar claro
Entonces ella está en una situación muy
grave Sí es que eso le quería preguntar
precisamente Omar porque pareciera que
esta situación de orden pública en el
Perú se le ha salido de las a la
presidenta Dina boluarte el día lunes
incluso fueron 17 personas en un solo
día
fallecidas que tiene que pasar qué tiene
que hacer o que pueda hacer el congreso
de Perú constitucionalmente para evitar
estas matanzas para evitar que se siguen
repitiendo muertos en el marco de estas
protestas en ese país
el congreso tiene que hacer lo contrario
de lo que ha hecho ayer porque ayer le
ha aprobado la cuestión de confianza
al ministro que es el responsable
político porque ha sido ministro de
defensa premiado con el ascenso a
presidente del Consejo de ministros de
la primera matanza Entonces el congreso
lo que está haciendo es convirtiéndose
en cómplice de lo que ha ocurrido y le
ha dado luz verde para que continúe con
esta política el congreso debió ayer
rechazarle la cuestión de confianza y
por lo tanto separarlo del cargo pero no
ha hecho eso Entonces en este momento
estamos en una situación
casi explosivo en términos políticos
Omar porque sí Perdón perdón que lo
interrumpa Pero cómo es que el congreso
peruano permite esto cuando se ha
caracterizado por ser un congreso
digamos que no le perdona mucho a los
presidentes que han pasado en estos
últimos años por qué en esta situación
no es tan grave cuando estamos hablando
de Vidas humanas que se han perdido en
protesta ciudadanas en las calles no ha
hecho nada para detener lo que está
ocurriendo
porque en este caso el Dina boluarte
apenas ascendió al poder
estableció una alianza con el congreso
claro digamos el congreso hoy día tiene
su mayoría un color político afín a Dina
boluarte Dina boluarte está en las
antípodas de lo que era el el
expresidente Castillo Un gobierno
nefasto y todo pero pero con una
orientación una determinada Dina
boluarte se ha convertido hoy día en una
presidenta que tiene el soporte de la
mayoría parlamentaria de derecha y de
las fuerzas armadas por eso es que la
mayoría parlamentaria ya casi le perdona
todo y es un congreso además que está
desprestigiado por un hecho que puede
parecer trivial pero no lo es en la
mañana de ayer
un congresista
había sido hace unos meses sí
sorprendido teniendo relaciones sexuales
con una trabajadora subordinada y
consumiendo licor en las instalaciones
del Congreso el Ministerio Público lo
acusado de violación el congreso tenía
que
destituirlo por juicio político por
infracción a la Constitución y qué pasó
ayer el congreso no lo destituyó ese
señor sigue siendo congresista ese
congreso desprestigiado es el que ha
mantenido en el cargo al responsable
político de la primera matanza ocurrida
en diciembre no digo responsable penal
sino responsable político es decir el
que debería irse del cargo por haber
permitido claro con su ineptitud por
decirlo menos porque no estamos hablando
de de de de criminalidad todavía sí de
que se produjeran diecisiete muertes por
uso de arma de fuego de las fuerzas de
seguridad en el mes de diciembre Ese es
el nivel de la Crisis que hay en el Perú
Omar por lo que por lo que estamos
conversando y y digamos por el apoyo
mayoritario del Congreso peruano Dylan
Duarte tendría Pues el apoyo para
continuar pero hasta qué punto digamos
los peruanos también van a permitir que
esto siga pasando
en un contexto de congreso como el que
estamos viendo en la actualidad
Sí el congreso del ejecutivo están de
espaldas al país claramente Dina
boluarte creo que es consciente de eso y
no ha aparecido en los medios ayer ayer
y hoy quien ha dado a quien ha dado la
cara es el presidente del Consejo de
ministros con una actitud prepotente
retadora inclusive
ha incurrido en este en esta especie de
de Sarcasmo trágico de expresar sus
condolencias a los a las víctimas a los
dedos de las víctimas de de este crimen
a decir que va a poner la bandera a
media asta
pero pero ninguna
ninguna responsabilidad ninguna
destitución a nadie es decir está
inclusive ha dicho se ha la que lamenta
las muertes pero se ha mantenido en
orden público en la misma posición
política sí de que el medio para
mantener el orden público es dispararle
a la gente claro